today on the matt walsh show the
prosecutors in the kyle rittenhouse case
made their closing arguments in their
case against self-defense in the second
amendment we'll take a look at the
closing arguments and we'll trace this
case all the way back to where it really
started because we shouldn't forget
about where where this all really began
also representative cory bush claims
that armed white supremacists shot at
her there is absolutely no evidence of
this of course and beto o'rourke runs
for governor plus a city in michigan
elects an all-muslim city council the
media says this is a great example of
racial diversity there are a number of
problems with that claim we'll discuss
and a feminist author says that many
women deeply regret having children and
getting married
is that true or just wishful thinking on
her part we'll talk about all that much
more today on the matt walsh show
you know i'm going to be getting on a
plane after the show and uh heading to
florida to speak at ave maria and um
looking forward to that on wednesday and
what that means is that of course i'm
going to make sure i have my trusty
relief band with me as i always do when
i travel relief band is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wrist band
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness which is my affliction anxiety
migraines hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug free non-drowsy
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed the technology was originally
developed over 20 years ago and 20 years
ago in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now the relief band it's
available to the masses how it works is
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of your
brain that controls nausea that it block
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach telling you that you're
sick and kind of
pulls a little bit of a slight of hand
trick on your own body in the process
and then you you don't feel the nausea
at all it's like magic relief band just
released its newest model relief band
sport the sport is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life so as the holiday season
quickly approaches there's never been a
better time to give the gift of relief
and make sure your loved ones are nausea
free right now relief band has an
exclusive offer just for matt walsh
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code wall she'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee so
head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off plus free shipping
we await now a verdict in the cal
rittenhouse case a verdict that should
be a foregone conclusion as the
prosecution utterly failed in its
responsibility to prove its case
but i don't feel as competent as i ought
to feel because i have very little faith
in our fundamental american institutions
like the justice system uh so many of us
have little faith in those institutions
if the bad guys win here and kyle is
successfully railroaded then faith in
those institutions will be finally and
irrevocably irrevocably broken for a lot
of people i suspect
what happens from there well nothing
good
again what makes this case unique is not
it's not simply that a corrupt d.a is
trying to destroy an innocent man though
that's exactly what he's doing
what makes it unique is that he's doing
it out in the open with the help of the
media and the democrat party and big
tech
these institutions have selected kyle as
their blood sacrifice and if they're
able to see this all the way through
and do this in front of everybody's eyes
while we know that they're doing it it
will mean that we have crossed a certain
threshold in this country
and i don't know if we'll be able to
reverse course at that point
now closing arguments were delivered on
monday prosecutors tweedledee and
tweedledum provided us with moments that
would almost be comedic relief
if not for the very serious stakes here
for example d.a binger in an attempt to
show that joseph rosenbaum was not a
serious threat
listed off all of the many crimes that
he committed on the night of his death
um it's not clear what point bingo
thought he was making here but let's
listen
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
uh that's like a lot of stuff
i mean he he committed more more arson
in 35 minutes than i have in 35 years so
now notably under any other any other
circumstance
most people on the left would say that a
white man deserves to be shot simply for
saying the n word leaving everything
else aside
remember a white macy's employee was
beaten senseless by a black man on
camera last summer remember that
and the violence was cheered by many
leftists because the assailant claimed
that the victim said the n-word now he
didn't that was all a lie
the point is simply that in most every
other case the n-word is treated as a
literal capital offense
but putting that aside by the da's
admission rosenbaum the child rapist
spent the whole night setting fires and
committing crimes before he attacked
written house
and the arsonist rapist was finally shot
not because of any of his previous
crimes even crimes committed that night
but because he charged and attempted to
assault a man carrying a rifle
all of his previous misdeeds were
irrelevant in that moment though it was
nice of the d.a to list them all again
for us i suppose
really it's tough to decide if that was
binger's dumbest moment yesterday
or maybe it was this
um here he is pointing an ar-15 at a
room full of people and you have to see
it to believe it i mean i i i heard
about this on twitter and i didn't
believe it until i saw the picture
and notice where his finger is placed
okay he's got his finger on the trigger
this is what we call bad trigger
discipline very bad
and it's the irony of all ironies
bingo has spent the whole trial accusing
rittenhouse of being reckless and
careless with his firearm and in this
culminating moment bingo decides to
basically nearly pull an alec baldwin on
the jury
quick note just to reiterate to anyone
watching at home
never ever point a weapon at anything or
anyone you don't intend to destroy
and never put your finger on the trigger
until you're ready to fire
you would think that the d.a who is
who is trying to prosecute somebody
right now i mean one of the charges that
was that was dismissed yesterday was a
you know firearms charge you know you'd
think maybe he knows would know a thing
or two about firearm safety but uh
apparently not
at another point after menacing the
entire courtroom by waving a rifle
around like a maniac um bingor gave his
theory of self-defense
and his theory as he explicitly states
is that self-defense is illegal
listen to this
they have to convince you that joseph
rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
use it on the defendant because they
know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun when
you're the one creating the damn danger
when you're the one provoking other
people
my god in heaven you lose the right to
self-defense when you're the one who
brought the gun
now if that's the case
then it is never acceptable to use your
gun in self-defense he is arguing that
shooting someone is always murder always
because by definition he says you lose
the right to shoot the gun the moment
you produce the gun
so you have the right to bear arms says
bingor you just don't have the right to
use them ever under any circumstance
those are the implications of the
statement that that we just heard him
make
and then more importantly the jury heard
him make
he is lying to them about the basic
facts of the law
forget about lying about the case we
know he's doing that
he's lying to the jury about what the
law says
and now you know this is this is where
some of my my uh pessimism comes from
in terms of the verdict
we have to trust that the jury is smart
enough to know what the law really is
even with the d.a standing there lying
to them for days on end
he also says that you can't claim
self-defense against an unarmed man
much of the prosecution's case rests on
the fact that the arsonist child rapist
did not have a weapon visible at the
time of the altercation
the assistant d.a went into a little bit
more detail on this point let's listen
to that
clearly if there is provocation
he's guilty but even outside of
provocation
why do you get to immediately just start
shooting
as mr binger said he brought a gun
to a fist fight
and he was too cowardly to use his own
fist to fight his way out
he has to start shooting
ladies and gentlemen of the jury have
you ever seen any of the jason bourne
films
jason bourne routinely defeats large
numbers of assailants using only his
fists and his wits
ladies and gentlemen justice demands
that we hold mr rittenhouse to the same
standard
if you've seen it in an action flick you
must convict
um sorry i don't mean to make fun of the
assistant d.a it's obvious for miss
physique that this man has lots of
experience in hand-to-hand combat i mean
he is the expert
but we can't all be trained kung fu
fighters like himself most of us are
mere mortals and it is asinine to
suggest that we have a legal or moral
obligation to fight an angry mob with
just our fists
it is equally asinine to argue that
unarmed mobs or even just an unarmed
individual isn't a potentially lethal
threat
maybe someone should ask reginald denny
about this
he's the white truck driver who was
pulled out of his truck during the la
race riots in the 90s and beaten
unconscious barely survived
suffered permanent physical impairments
because of the attack
does the d.a of kenosha think that we
have an obligation to submit ourselves
to permanent physical disability for the
sake of preserving the lives of the
violent animals assaulting us
what would the prosecution say to
reginald denny
well i guess they'd say this
everybody takes a beating sometimes
right sometimes you get in a
a scuffle and maybe you do get hurt a
little bit
uh just a scuffle
some cuts and bruises everybody takes a
beating sometimes
i mean the assistant d.a tripped and
bruised his knee on the way into krispy
kreme the other week so he's been there
and done that
no big deal
and what they argue now is that whenever
you're assaulted by someone your
responsibility is to take the beating
and to preserve the life of your
assailant even if that means giving up
your own life in the process
this of course is suicidal
amoral
the prosecution has waged an all-out
assault on the dignity and worth of
human life all under the guise
of defending the dignity and worth of
human life
but no matter how they present it what
they're saying is that your life is so
worthless so lacking in value that you
should be willing to forfeit it you
should be ready to jump on the grenade
if ever if you know if ever some scumbag
criminal decides to attack you
according to the d.a that's how
worthless you are
the scumbag criminal if if a child
rapist comes after you to beat you
senseless
your life is so worthless that you
should
even if you have the ability to stop him
you shouldn't
as i've said all along they have put our
right to self-defense on trial but you
could even say that they've put the
value of human life on trial
there is a caveat here though
for the left to include the prosecution
in this case
the right to self-defense is it's not
that it doesn't exist completely
um it's it's just that it's conditional
and not conditional based on
circumstance but based on identity and
politics
see it's really impossible to understand
much of the liberal analysis of the
written house case until you understand
that most of it is founded on the
assumption that the rioters had the
moral right to destroy property as they
pleased
and anybody who tried to prevent them
from doing so was infringing on those
rights
see this is the crucial point for them
this is what it all comes down to
from the perspective of reality and
common sense
the prosecution claim that kyle
rittenhouse provoked his attackers makes
no sense he wasn't the one rioting he
didn't go there that night with the
intent of committing a crime unlike the
looters and rioters
they attacked him because he wanted to
prevent them from committing crimes
they provoked the altercation that led
to their own deaths
he didn't bring a gun to a fist fight
they brought a if anything they brought
a fist
fist to a gunfight
or rather at least they brought fists to
a to a guy who was carrying a gun that's
on them
you know that's them writing a check
they couldn't cash
but this is all the way that a normal
sane morally decent person sees it but
the abnormal insane morally repugnant
hordes again to include the d.a
actually believe that the rioters were
entitled to burn and destroy
remember a few years ago the mayor of
baltimore saying about rioters in that
city we have to give them space to
destroy
and that was not a gaffe okay she was
articulating the leftist view of these
situations
their alleged emotional trauma granted
them the right to do as they pleased if
they felt that the path to emotional
healing was to burn a convenience store
or loot a foot locker
then they were morally sanctioned to do
so
so looking at it from this drunken
discombobulated perspective it makes
sense that kyle rittenhouse is the
provoker and the aggressor he was there
to prevent them from exercising their
right to riot
when they chased an assault on him they
were acting in defense of that right in
self-defense which meant that he had no
right to respond with lethal force
that's the way they see it
the d.a has all but argued this
explicitly
one other point i want to make here in
the lead-up to the verdict
which could come
any minute
let's remember how this all began
it began not when kyle rittenhouse
showed up in kenosha with his weapon
but days before that when accused rapist
jacob blake accosted a woman
fought the cops who showed up to save
her
pulled a knife
and tried to steal a vehicle with
children inside
he was justifiably shot both local and
federal authorities
okay the biden administration included
have looked at the shooting and have
confirmed that the shooting was
justified
but the media lied about that case
and they used it to intentionally
provoke more rioting
and then when kyle came along and did
what he had to do
they lied about that too
if kyle is rightfully exonerated they'll
lie some more and try to set the city on
fire all over again they truly are the
enemy of the people
what's more the media has no right to do
what it's doing
let's be clear about that too
okay they don't this is this this free
speech does not cover this
it has no right to lie and instigate and
intentionally provoke and incite
and rip our country to pieces on purpose
many of them should be in prison for
what they've done in kenosha and what
they will continue to do
they are the villains here
and we should never forget that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we're all looking for every possible way
that we can find to save a little bit of
money and uh here's a great way in an
easy way get upside it's called the get
upside app
and uh it's because it's all it really
is all upside for you you're saving
money every time you go and pump your
gas my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back
don't pay full price of the pump anymore
there's no reason get cash back using
get upside just download the app for
free and use promo code walsh to get up
to 50 cents a gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash is is added to
your account you can do it uh if you you
can cash out to your bank account paypal
you can get an e gift card on amazon or
somewhere else and it is really as
simple as that you're saving money every
time you go to the pump just download
the free get upside app and use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on your first tank
that's code walsh
okay um
here's just another perfect example of
the convoluted thinking of the left on
this tom nichols who's uh you know never
trump
guy i think he i think at one point he
claimed to be conservative i'm not sure
but uh tom nichols on twitter he says
everyone involved would be alive if he
written house had stayed home with his
mommy instead of going to play hero in a
neighboring state
this this is the frustration where you
want to grab these people by the collar
and like shake them and say they were at
a rot what about the rioters this was a
riot
what about them well why didn't kyle
rittenhouse just stay home that night
why didn't they all stay home that night
they want to analyze this case
pretend in that happened in the context
of a riot and pretend the riot wasn't
happening
everyone would be alive if kyle had
stayed home that night
he's the one who should have stayed home
not the child rapist who according to
the d.a was just running around the city
setting stuff on fire
but as i said i've already explained
where this really comes from they
had the right to do that
because they were upset because their
tummies hurt
um because uh because a a another rapist
had been shot by the cops while trying
to abduct some children
in a stolen vehicle
and that made their tummies hurt and
they were really upset about that
or at least they were pretending to be
upset about that
and so they had the right to do whatever
they wanted to do
all right um let's start with this a
tweet from corey bush representative
cory bush
let's remember that she is an elected
representative she's she is a member of
congress
and here's what she tweeted
she said when we marched in ferguson
white supremacists would hide behind a
hill near where michael j michael brown
jr was murdered and shoot at us
they never faced consequences
if kyle rittenhouse gets acquitted it
tells them that even seven years later
they still can get away with it
i mean
where do you even begin here how where
do you start
um
this isn't even the most important point
but what do you mean hid behind a hill
i'm trying to figure the figure out the
the physics of that exactly logistically
how does that work they're hiding behind
a hill
and shooting at you and this is
this is in the the in the middle of the
city there's a big
hill that they can hi i'm i'm trying to
imagine how that even works and i can't
but of course it doesn't have to work in
reality because she completely made this
up
i mean
when did this happen
exactly
is there any evidence of this so there
were there were white there were armed
white supremacist militants in ferguson
after uh michael brown was killed and
that by the way also
an entirely justified shooting
and that was also vindicated by local
authorities and the federal government
under the which at the time was under
the direction of barack obama barack
obama's uh
doj
tried to find a way to
uh
you know tried to find some charges to
hang on the officer in that case
and couldn't find them
but yet they still use the michael brown
case
as an example
of police brutality and white
supremacist violence and all this kind
of stuff
a democratic administration
already debunked that
and they still use it
because the truth is irrelevant to them
of course
um
but she says that after this happened
there were there were militant white
supremacists on the scene shooting at
people
and this never made the news the media
decided not to report this fact
were they shouting this is mega country
while they shot maybe
uh but of course this is a brazen lie
from a from a
a sitting u.s congresswoman but she lies
brazenly because she knows she'll get
away with it she knows that there is
there's no possible consequence to her
because she's a democrat
and also because of all of the identity
politics
points that she that she can check off
as a black woman so
you know that gives her all the cover in
the world and she could she could say
whatever she wants
nobody will follow up no one in the
media will even ask her about this
and that and that tells you everything
you you need to know that that shows
that they know it's a lie because if
they thought there was any chance that
this actually happened
then they'd want to talk about it
they'd want to get her in front of a
camera and say tell us all about this
horrible experience with white
supremacists shooting at you
but they know it's totally bogus and so
they're not going to ask her about it
and of course we haven't even gotten to
the fact that she connects kyle
rittenhouse she puts him in the same
category
as white supremacists
um when
that's
just a flat out lie once again
but also everybody involved in this case
is white
they're all white people
i just so there's another tweet from uh
i don't have it in front of me but
some blue check leftist
someone in the media sang saying that
employers after the kyle rittenhouse
verdict comes down no matter what the
verdict is
this guy on twitter is saying that the
employers should give black employees
the day off give them a couple days off
you know because of how emotional this
case is for the for the black employees
what
black people there's there are no there
are no black individuals involved in
this case this is a white person who
shot three other white people who were
attacking him
but it doesn't matter the truth is the
truth is completely irrelevant um
and that is really what they that's
that's what they think this is ends
justify the means
the truth is uh you know the truth is
subjective
so the way they look at it with kyle
rittenhouse yeah there's of course he's
not a white supremacist
uh race has nothing to do with this case
whatsoever because everybody involved is
the same race
but the truth that's you know that might
be the truth that might be the reality
but it's not their reality it's not
their truth
and their truth is determined by how
they feel
so they when they see this case
it feels to them like kyle rittenhouse
must be a white supremacist
and it feels to them like he's guilty of
mass murder
and because they feel that that's the
case then then it is the case then it's
true if you feel it then it's true
that's how they see it
all right next we got beta o'rourke is
uh let's see he tried to be he tried to
run for senator that didn't work out
tried to run for president that didn't
exactly work out and now
maybe third time's a charm he's running
for governor let's watch his
announcement
i'm running for governor and i want to
tell you why
this past february when the electricity
grid failed and millions of our fellow
texans were without power which meant
that the lights wouldn't turn on the
heat wouldn't run and pretty soon their
pipes froze and the water stopped
flowing they were abandoned by those who
are elected to serve and look out for
them
it's a symptom of a much larger problem
that we have in texas right now those in
positions of public trust have stopped
listening to
serving and paying attention to and
trusting the people of texas and so
they're not focused on the things that
we really want them to do like making
sure that we have a functioning
electricity grid or that we're creating
the best jobs in america right here in
texas or that we have world-class
schools or that we make progress on the
things that most of us actually agree on
like expanding medicaid or legalizing
marijuana
instead they're focusing on the kind of
extremist policies around abortion or
permit-less carry or even in our schools
that really only divide us and keep us
apart and stop us from working together
on the truly big things that we want to
achieve for one another
why did i play so much of that clip i
have no idea
but you have to respect in a way just
how how blatant
that o'rourke is
he's desperate to be in charge somehow
of someone he's just desperate for
something
he wants the attention he wants to be in
charge he's power hungry he's attention
starved and so he's he's running through
is that i'll okay i'll i'll be senator i
think i think i'm cut out for that nope
you don't want me for that okay then how
about i'll be president no okay well how
about all right then i'll be governor oh
no not that well then i'll be um
i don't know i'll be the i'll be the
captain of the bowling team how about
that
and i love how he talks about um well
the people have said we we have to we
have to get down to what the people of
texas really care about
you know what are the things that really
affect their lives
yeah uh equity intolerance have some
more drag queen story hours because that
that's what the democrat party thinks
people actually care about and want
once again of course
what you hear there the opposite is the
reality
that what makes the democrat party what
makes democrats democrat governors and
democrats at every level what makes them
um
ineffectual what makes them impotent
leaders
makes them bad leaders
is that they're
they have they're totally unconcerned
about about the practical
everyday
act of governing
they don't care about people's everyday
lives
that's why they're so dismissive of
inflation gas prices going up supply
chain crisis
what do we hear from democrats in the
media
well you know it's it just deal with it
you'll be fine
so you got to buy one less tv what's the
big deal
you got to pay a little bit more for
milk i mean come on just just drink less
milk
these are the everyday practical things
that affect people's lives and that's
exactly what they don't care about
because on the left
all
all that matters is ideology
so they are always in service to
ideology
you know if you have a democrat governor
of texas he's not he's not serving the
people of texas he's serving the
ideology first and foremost
um
i think better o'rourke just had he has
some sort of
he is he is playing out his fetish in in
in real time in front of the in front of
the entire world he is he's a
humiliation fetish a fetish for losing
and i really i would appreciate it if he
would keep this behind closed doors we
don't all have to witness it
um tony fauci has some thoughts about
the liberty versus safety debate as he
continues to morph into just a full-on
super villain and he even kind of looks
like one now uh let's watch that
well one of the things that to me was
most
difficult to accept is that we put
together a good plan
for how we were going to try and dampen
down
the spread of infection early on
thinking that that was accepted by
everybody and then
the next day
the president saying free michigan free
virginia
i i didn't quite understand
what the purpose of that was except to
put
this misplaced perception about people's
individual right to make a decision
that supersedes the societal safety it
was at that point
that i realized that i would have to
just get out there myself and
say things that clearly were going to be
contradictory
you know for me the main point there is
he's wearing a turtleneck underneath a
button down and a suit jacket
that's that's that's what i'm focusing
on first and foremost
oh but what we have uh you know making
decisions that that undermine the
societal safety whatever the heck that's
supposed to mean
um as
fouchy just becomes in and he's been
pretty explicit about this the entire
time but
you know we know traditionally in
america what our founding fathers always
said is
is it is uh is that we we don't
sacrifice liberty for safety and he's
he's been pretty straightforward about
saying no it's the other way around
give up all your freedoms and we'll keep
you safe
um okay i want to mention this this is
from nbc a city in michigan
is apparently the first in the nation to
elect an all muslim city council
reflecting a more racially diverse
landscape in local governance
three candidates won election to the
city council and um
hamtramck
last week h-a-m-t-r-a-m-c-k
is the name of the town how do you
pronounce that
um i'm not great with pronunciation but
you've got you know you've got three
consonants in a row so what am i
supposed to do with that
all six identify as muslim
hamtremec part of the greater detroit
area also elected its first muslim mayor
to round out the city's government
the muslim public affairs council a
national american muslim advocacy and
public policy organization said it's the
first and only city that they're aware
of that has a full muslim city council
of mayor
so
a couple of problems here first of all
uh we we see this this same confusion
with the media where they seem to think
that muslim is a race so they say well
they elected
in all muslim city council which is a
reflection of racial diversity
muslim again is not actually race it's a
religion
don't mean to split hairs there but i
don't think it's really splitting hairs
i think it's an important point
but also how is this diversity
it's people of all the same
quote-unquote race
to use the media's language
so in all muslim
you have a city council where it's all
one identity group
and that's diversity
well no remember what we talked about
yesterday when it comes to diversity
uh as i said this is this is a perfect
example of the point i was making
yesterday
diversity
when you hear someone on the left talk
about diversity
what they really mean is
getting rid of the white males
that's what it means
and that's why as long as you get the
white males out they don't really care
what the racial makeup is
so they're not in all all muslim all uh
people of middle eastern descent that's
perfectly fine
they're not going to worry about hey
maybe we should get a black person in
there uh maybe we should get a
transgender person in there
if it was all males they wouldn't worry
about that
just as long as you get the white males
out
the the push for diversity is a push for
excluding white males from
society and that is again proven
by the fact that as long as you never
hear them complain ever there is never a
complaint about diversity
in any in any institutional organization
as long as the white males are pushed
out
you get them out and it doesn't matter
what the makeup is what the percentages
are makes no difference
diversity is i say again an anti-white
male conspiracy that's what it is
which which is which is the only way i
mean that's the only way to make sense
of the claim that an all muslim city
council is diverse
all right um so i've had this for a few
days i've wanted to play here's a cnn
contributor who is uh allegedly a
republican at least at one point as
republican i don't know if he still
considers himself one he uh is laughing
about parents who are worried that kids
are being exposed to pornography
pornographic content at school he thinks
that's hilarious and let's listen to him
i was just to say real quick all those
parents worried about pornography in the
literature
kids ain't worried about pornography
literally you better take your son's
phone and take a look at what that bad
boy is
you baby you better you better hello
go to go to that go to that uh that
school that school dance and see what
they doing out behind the school baby
come on now these parents acted like
they were teenagers
[Laughter]
hello
and they don't have the kid's password
so even if they got the phone they
couldn't see what's on it because they
don't even know what their kids are
watching
on the phone
uh in incredible insight and analysis
from the from them hello that's that's
what we're getting now from from msnbc
um but it's it's not really even funny i
mean to to these
degenerate weirdos you know
the idea that we should protect our
children from pornographic content it's
uh it's hilarious they they it's it's
funny to them
they're not simply disagreeing they
think it's funny they're laughing
at you as a parent and you're concerned
for
protecting um the the innocence of your
children
and the way they look at it is you know
there's there's there's no point i mean
they see and
being pretty honest about it here
the way they the way they see it kids
are already sexualized
um there's no point in trying to stop it
there's no point in trying to prevent it
and protect them
and if they're being exposed to
pornography on the phone then you might
as well expose them to it at school
you know once once that threshold has
been crossed then you know hey
game on the way they the way they
figured and if there are parents who
have successfully
uh protected their kids from this kind
of content well you know those those
those parents have their kids in a
bubble and it's it's for the kid's own
benefit that they are removed from that
bubble whether the parents want them to
or not
but by the way just so you know
it is actually possible i'm not saying
it's necessarily easy
um it is possible
to protect your kids from this kind of
content
i mean
michael steele there is is right about
one thing
he's right that if you're if your kid
has a has a smartphone
if you give a smartphone to your kid
with internet access
i mean it almost doesn't matter how old
they are
and if they've had it for any length of
time
then they've almost certainly been
exposed to all manner of filth and
objectionable content that you as a
parent shouldn't want them to see so
he's right about that
he's wrong in thinking that it's funny
that the corruption of kids to him is is
is a funny thing he's wrong about that
you know and he's also wrong that
even if that's true that it somehow
justifies pornographic content at school
but it is correct
that's something parents need to need to
understand
if you give this kind of if you give
that sort of tool to your child who is
not old enough to use it
appropriately
um then he is going to be exposed to it
and it's got nothing to do with i hear
from parents sometimes who say uh well i
i you know i i trust my kids
i trust them
and that's why i'll give them the phone
this is not about this is not about
trust
kids at a certain age don't have the
psychological
ability
to um
to navigate cyberspace to navigate the
internet
and avoid this kind of
content this this is where the idea of
consent
this is why we say that children are not
old enough to consent to sexual activity
well they're also not even if if you
give them the phone and they make the
quote-unquote choice to click on
something
or to go to pornhub or whatever
it's not really a choice because they
can't actually consent to being exposed
to that
when you when you watch pornography you
are being
you are
you are now involved in someone else's
sexual activity
you're you are involved as a spectator
but that still is involvement
you are in a certain way taking part in
this activity
and whatever choice a child makes with
the phone it's not really a choice
because they cannot choose that
all of our laws on consent are based
on the assumption the correct assumption
that children are not psychologically
capable of making that kind of choice
so you give it you give the phone to
your child this is what's going to
happen
uh so as as i
always say just take the there's no
reason there's there's no real good
reason to let your kid have the phone
for just take the phone away
if you're worried about their you know
they need to be able to get a hold of
you or something like that
um
give them a phone give them a flip phone
no internet access
well the other kids you know think it's
funny yeah but but who cares
you can
preserve your child's innocence
um or you can protect them from the
snickering and laughing from other kids
you can kind of choose which one you're
going to prioritize as a parent
what else we got here this is from the
independent a police report was filed
following the recent on a on stage
urination incident during a performance
by u.s ban brass against
last week the group's singer sophia
urista
was filmed urinating on a fan's face
midway through a rendition of rage
against the machine to wake up in
daytona florida
before inviting the man to lie down on
stage arista had told the crowd i gotta
pee and i can't make it to the bathroom
so we might as well make a show out of
it
and she peed on the guy's face
on stage the band subsequently
apologized for the incident writing on
twitter sophia got carried away that's
not something the rest of us expected
and it's not something you'll see again
at our shows
thanks for bringing it last night
daytona
she got carried away that's why she peed
on a guy's face i this this is just this
is
this is gross i can't even joke about it
uh piss poor judgment by everybody
involved
all i can say to the singer is you're in
trouble
and i i think that from what i
understand sophia is from france because
i heard someone in the uh in the
audience point at her and say european
so but at least the fan had a vip ticket
sorry
that's i in all seriousness this is
degenerate filth i hope everybody
involved is arrested i mean everybody
involved even people in the audience i
think just
guilt by association arrest them to
arrest everybody that's my real opinion
of this
now let's get to the comment section
[Music]
very excited to be able to tell you once
again about american financing what if
you could lower your mortgage rate
without adding years to your loan
potentially saving hundreds of dollars a
month and tens of thousands long term
well fortunately for you it's possible
when you call american financing
america's home for home loans you'll
start with a free mortgage review from
one of their salary-based mortgage
experts so you can understand all of
your home loan options and make it very
easy for you from flexible terms to
competitive rates and fast clothings
closings they've got they've got you
covered you really can save up to a
thousand dollars a month with these guys
and you could choose any term 10 years
and over um with all the money that were
that seems to be you know draining from
our accounts with how expensive
everything is these days
why not save money on your mortgage when
you have this opportunity custom loans
don't get any better than this so what
are you waiting for make the 10 minute
no obligation call now learn about
custom loan options and get these
savings as soon as possible you can even
skip two mortgage payments at the same
time but you've got to call now 866
569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
diane says i get the point matt was
making about diversity in the military
however he did throw down the gauntlet i
would suggest the navajo code talkers is
a historical example of when diversity
helped our military win
uh well no that's not an example of
diversity helping the military win
because the example that you're
providing is all about skill ingenuity
effectiveness
that's not diversity
okay this is this is not this is not in
world war ii we made the decision that
we're going to prioritize diversity
and um and then and so that that's why
we're going to bring no this was
that was not diversity for diversity
sake
so when i say that diversity itself has
never helped any military win any
engagement
that is not to say
that every victorious military has to be
racially homogenous that's not the point
it's just that everybody involved you
know they should be there operating as
one unit
and um the top priority is to
effectively defeat the enemy
and they are going to utilize any
strategies and bring in anybody they
need to bring in to um
achieve that that that goal
okay those are the the
victorious uh
armies that do that
when you prioritize diversity when
you're when you're bringing people in
not because of their skills not because
they're qualified
not because they're going to be
effective killers of the enemy but
you're bringing them in just to fit some
kind of racial quota
that's the problem that's what i'm
talking about
nick says is anyone else's favorite part
of the matt wall show when matt
describes his weekend in everyday
interactions with his wife kids and
family whenever matt briefly mentions
his kids waking up singing for example
it still cracks me up as much as it did
the first time and then paul responds to
nick's comment and says i don't like the
family stories i don't know them or care
what they do i want the time spent on
relevant topics
all right paul what am i just a piece of
meat to you
you don't want to know about me and my
life
you just want to hear the opinions huh
i feel so objectified
uh ted says
uh quoting matt walsh says he wants
slave labor for his show media matters
well yeah i did i actually did say
exactly that i am looking for uh you
know
for some slave labor
um not a racial thing you know i'll take
uh slaves of any race whatsoever all can
apply for the internship for the slavery
slash internship position
candid apple says do this matt when our
oldest son had picked up the santa thing
and it was time for him to grow out of
it we told him the secret that santa was
a real person who lived a long time ago
who was loving and gave gifts to people
and that ever since people have
continued to give gifts in his name the
people who know this secret and
keep it can now be santa and set the
presents under the tree he loved it and
was so excited to sneak through the
house at midnight to put the presents
under the tree this also prevents your
kids from being those brats who make the
public announcement at the school lunch
table santa's not real
um yeah i mean that's if you got to
break the news that's i think probably
the best way to do it
not a lot of consolation in that though
when you say that well you know santa
was real sort of but he lived a long
time ago and now he's dead
not a great consolation there hey sorry
kid you missed him
yeah i mean if you happen to be alive uh
1500 years ago then maybe you could have
seen santa he's been he's dead now
decomposing
um so you can which is better to tell
your kids when you're breaking the news
that santa isn't real or that he's dead
that's an interesting question
i guess if you really want to save
yourself from the charge of lying you
could always tell your kids
i mean now you're lying some more but
another way to go about it is to say hey
listen uh
you know santa's he's not
he's not here anymore
he doesn't exist oh you mean you lied to
me no no he was he he he died actually
last night so he's dead now he's gone we
got to move on from santa i didn't lie
to you but now he's dead
uh another comment says i don't think
you ever need to tell your kids santa
isn't real they'll just naturally figure
it out when they're old enough well no
it's not natural uh it's not it's not
it's not like a natural process of
evolution this is
some other kid is gonna tell them and
tell them in a mocking way there's going
to be that conversation where another
kid says
you still believe in santa and then and
like they could learn that way
that's the natural way as you put it or
you can tell them
you can talk to them in a safe
environment
or you're not going to make fun of them
because that would be adding insult to
injury to tell your kid santa isn't real
than to say i can't believe you ever
bought that idiot
don't do that when you tell your kids
um and finally the amateur says matt why
would you lie to your kids about the
mythical nature of santa my parents
never even allowed us to believe the
santa was real despite how the world
works and let us know that our parents
uh our presence came from them to
appropriately place our gratitude also
jesus being the reason for the season i
expect better of you
ah yeah yeah your parents are so much
better than me thank you for that i i
can only hope to bask in their uh
in in in the light of their superiority
so thank you for that
now again you
i take from your comment here you're
talking about your parents that means
that you don't have kids
okay
and don't take this the wrong way but in
general
if you don't have kids
your opinion on anything parent-related
is completely irrelevant and silly
no offense
uh here's what you have to understand
about about young kids
the
the words not real
to a young child
don't mean anything
okay that doesn't
they don't at
a certain age kids who are three four
years old
they don't understand the difference
between fantasy and reality
there's just a conceptual
disconnect
and so you can you can tell them you
could say well santa's not real that
doesn't mean anything to them
because to them in their you know they
they feel like santa is real i mean and
then leftists as they even as adults
they still operate this way they operate
like a four-year-old
um all four-year-olds are kind of
leftist in a certain way so at four they
from from their perspective they feel
like santa is real they've seen him on
tv they've seen him at the mall and to
say he's not real even though i've seen
him and i feel like he's real
to them that doesn't mean anything
and that's why as i said yesterday kids
also at that
age uh believe that dragons are real and
fairies are real
and they think that all the superheroes
that they see on tv are also real and
flying around that's the world they live
in and it's a it's a fun world it's much
more fun in the real world let's be
honest
in order to break your kids
and to make sure of of this belief
you have to take all of those fantasies
and all of that imagination away from
them
did your parents also work really hard
to make sure you didn't believe in
dragons and fairies
when you came in and said oh daddy i saw
a fairy in the garden no you didn't
fairies aren't real
is that how it worked see i'm not going
to do that to my kids
and that's why
it goes this way it's certainly no
secret that the left is attempting to
force compliance across the board
whether it's the media lying to push the
left's gun control narrative over the
course of the written house trial or the
federal government's attempt to enforce
vaccine mandates on employers it's
become patently obvious that compliance
is the goal why because the left doesn't
want you to have autonomy over your own
body they don't want you to be able to
defend yourself nor do they want you to
stay employed if you want to comply to
them that's why we here at the daily
wire are fighting every day against
tyranny from our honest coverage of the
written house trial to the lawsuit we've
taken out against the biden
administration for their
unconstitutional vaccine mandates we're
applying the pressure and we're already
creating change the fifth circuit court
of appeals issued a temporary stay
preventing biden's mandate from going
into effect citing grave statutory and
constitutional issues however biden is
determined to pass these mandates and we
cannot let our guard down for a second
we're not just fighting for the daily
wire employees we're fighting for all
americans this is an urgent matter and
your freedom depends on it if you want
to support the fight to make your
personal medical decisions without
government interference sign our
petition against the buying
administration's authoritarian mandate
hundreds of thousands of americans have
already signed the petition we need more
people to sign it so please head to
dailywire.com do not comply to sign the
petition today and finally the most
important thing to tell you about what
i've been waiting
to get to
if you haven't signed up for my
newsletter yet i highly recommend you do
so now not only does signing up bring
you a bundle of theocratic fascist joy
to your inbox every friday your
subscription will also put you in the
running to win the banjo which is
currently sitting behind me the one that
the um that our alien friend our pilgrim
alien is is has been taken care of for
so long uh we are going we're going to
be giving that banjo away this is your
opportunity to own
a banjo that has
been owned and as you know played
by the the probably the most legendary
banjo player um in in american history
which would be myself um you don't want
to miss it the incredibly lucky winner
gets my banjo and it's not going to be
you if you don't sign up for the
newsletter just head to dailywire.com
banjo to subscribe to my newsletter
which always is full of the best writing
you'll read all week
i don't know about the best but it's you
know okay and get entered to win my
beautiful banjo thank you in advance
advance i look forward to seeing your
name on my subscriber list now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel a woman by the name of
jessica taylor uh dr jessica taylor to
be specific she has a phd in forensic
psychology and for some reason needs
that piece of paper acknowledged every
time someone says her name
she's also a self-described radical
feminist author who recently wrote the
book sexy but psycho
i don't know anything about the book but
based on the title i'm going to assume
that it's half biography and half
fiction i'll let you decide which half
is which in any case yesterday dr taylor
tweeted this she says i wish there was
more honesty in the world about how many
women feel trapped by motherhood
marriage and being a 24 7 slave to men
and children whilst the tv and magazines
frame it as some sort of feminine ideal
bliss so many women regret it but they
can't say a word
she continues in a follow-up she says it
really is one of the biggest taboos in
the world women who regret having
children or regret getting married or
both the women who had big plans big
personalities big ambitions to find
themselves trapped for decades making
themselves feel smaller and smaller
okay now to use the tedious modern
cliche there's a lot to unpack here
first of all
you might ask how jessica knows what
many women think and feel if by her
admission they don't say a word
it would seem that she has a prejudice
against marriage and family life and
merely assumes that the prejudice must
be shared by most other people which is
common in narcissists
they struggle to see the world as
distinct from themselves
as a narcissist you know she can't
fathom that other humans exist in the
world as holy separate entities and live
their own lives just as vivid as her own
and may see things differently and have
different feelings
she also knows that if she is alone in
her contempt for the nuclear family or
in a minority at least
then that makes her simply a bitter
lonely person
it would mean that it's it's possible
for her to be another way
that another path was available
but she chose this instead
and she can't face that possibility so
she projects her neuroses and her
hatreds onto others
and you know i was able to come up with
that whole diagnosis without even
getting my psychiatry phd that's how
good i am
now that aside there are a few other
pieces of this puzzle that need closer
inspection in fact nearly every word is
wrong so it might be best to go again
line by line and discover just how much
wrongness there is here
so again she begins i wish there was
more honesty in the world about how many
women feel trapped by motherhood
marriage and being a 24 7 slave to men
and children okay the problem there
is most obviously that she compares
motherhood and wife and wifehood to
slavery
the difference though is that women
choose to be mothers and wives unless
they live in like saudi arabia or
something but jessica doesn't make that
stipulation these rad femmes never do
they tend to let the the fundamentalist
muslim world off the hook completely but
apart from instances of
arranged marriages and actual sex
slavery and that sort of thing
this is a life that women choose
also in slavery you're producing goods
or performing a service for someone else
with no benefit to yourself in
motherhood you're helping to build and
maintain a family your own family it is
yours you are giving yourself to
something that is yours in a very
intimate and personal sense and in that
you find another crucial distinction
slavery is dehumanizing a person in
slavery is not a person but a machine
that'll be the case for our intern
whenever we hire one and family life on
the other hand
you are fulfilled you're made whole
you're edified completed lifted up by
your relationship with your family and
your service to your family
i could go on but hopefully i've already
given enough differences between
motherhood and slavery to convince you
hopefully you didn't need to be
convinced in the first place continuing
she says
whilst the tv and magazines frame it
marriage motherhood as some sort of
feminine ideal bliss
now this would be a good point if it was
coming from someone who hasn't watched
any tv show or film or read any magazine
since about the year 1942
in modern times however hollywood is
constantly hammering on the point that
the traditional suburban white picket
fence life is actually a grim dystopian
hell
that's what american beauty was all
about and many films before and since
have revisited that theme
hollywood at some point discovered the
shocking truth that sometimes women in
single-family homes in the suburbs
aren't happy and they since decided that
all women in those types of setups are
unhappy all the time that they're all
having illicit affairs and their
husbands are all closeted homosexuals
this has been hollywood's version of
suburbia for decades now jessica in fact
got this idea from hollywood
then she says it really is one of the
biggest taboos in the world women who
regret having children or regret getting
married or both
now this goes back to the first line
where she calls for honesty
it's pretty common these days for people
to confuse self-centered whining with
taboo breaking honesty
and we see it again here
i mean we've all known people in our
lives who profess that they want to be
honest about their feelings and what
that means in practice is just that they
complain all the time and they whine
about every misfortune or discomfort and
they expect you to pity them for their
troubles but also admire them for their
bold and courageous honesty at the same
time
but the fact is that even if a woman is
feeling unhappy at home or in her
marriage
she should not be honest about it in the
sense of talking about it publicly
she especially should not be honest
about her regrets about having children
if she is in fact experiencing those
regrets
i doubt that those regrets are nearly as
common as jessica believes in hopes
but if a certain portion of women feel
that way but they don't say it out loud
good for them they shouldn't say it out
loud
your parenting regrets are the kind of
thing you keep to yourself
a burden you carry on your own
as you work to fix whatever character
defect has caused you to feel that way
finally she refers to the women who had
big plans big personalities and big
ambitions find themselves trapped for
decades making themselves smaller and
smaller
now i fail to see why anyone's
personality should be constrained by
marriage and family life my wife
has personality for days if anything her
personality has become bigger and more
boisterous since i met her some of that
may be compensation for the fact that
she married a cynical bastard i don't
know
but as for big plans and big ambitions i
mean what do you mean
sitting in a cubicle
working in middle management somewhere
being on a payroll
those are the big plans
there's no reason why a woman can't do
those things also while having a family
many women do
but the way these people paint the
working world is some kind of utopia
where dreams are fulfilled and people
become larger and more vivid and more
interesting human beings
i find that laughable especially coming
from people who most of the time
fashion themselves as anti-corporate
socialists
so which is it
is the corporate world the fulfillment
of a woman's dreams and the avenue to
her liberation and happiness or is it
exploitation
and its own form of slavery
the left's opinion on the subject seems
to change with the tide as with every
other subject
it's all a mess therefore just like
jessica's worldview and probably her
life as well
now i don't think that working a job is
exploitation
but i do know that in the working world
in your job you are completely
replaceable
you will leave your job one day and
you'll be replaced the next day and
nobody will remember you or care that
you're gone
the hole you leave behind will be filled
as quickly as it was made and that will
be it
in your family that's not the case
if you leave your family through death
or by your own choice or however
whatever the case
a whole will be left behind that nobody
will ever fill completely and you will
be missed and remembered and the impact
you made will be felt for better or
worse for generations
that's the difference between your job
and your family
and it's another reason why everything
jessica said is wrong every word every
line every assumption underpinning it
her ideas are silly and trite and out of
touch and sad and wrong but other than
that great points thanks jessica also
you're canceled
i'll leave it there today thanks for
watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright
dailywire 2021.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode the kyle rittenhouse
case wraps up vice president kamala
harris faces growing media scrutiny and
new polling shows americans turning on
the biden administration over
immigration
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire